BIRT box made a quick nest for itself in
the pop culture zeitgeist and viewers
are wondering if they'll see any more
from that world netflix hasn't announced
any plans to produce a sequel to its
record-breaking hit but that doesn't
mean we won't see a follow up at some
point here's everything we know about a
possible bird box sequel Netflix proudly
touted bird box as an instant success
for claiming that it had been watched by
more than 45 million accounts in its
first week of release the best opening
ever for the streaming service Netflix
chief content officer Ted Saran doze
previously compared the 20 million
streams four at the Christmas Chronicles
to a two hundred million dollar movie
opening by that metric bird box netting
more than double those views would
easily make it one of the biggest movies
of 2018 the accuracy of the analogy can
be debated but even if Netflix is
exaggerating the numbers the movie still
seems like a staggering success and in
Hollywood success usually brings sequels
such was the case with bright the
fantasy buddy cop movie starring Will
Smith and Joel Edgerton after a strong
opening on the platform with 11 million
reported streams in its first three days
Netflix made the decision to go ahead
with a sequel it's also a movie that had
a far larger production budget than Burt
box 90 million dollars compared to
nineteen point eight million dollars for
the moment Netflix has said that there
are no plans to make bird box 2 but that
doesn't mean the idea has been totally
ruled out after fans clamored for a
follow-up to the teen rom-com to all the
boys I've loved before the company
announced a second film of course the
situation is a little different with
that movie which is based on the first
book of a trilogy by Jenny Han in other
words their source material out there
for a second to all the boys feature
that's not the case with bird box the
only thing that will happen soon is
we're all gonna die soon bird box is
based on the Josh malar Minh novel of
the same name though screenwriter Eric
Heiser and director susanne bier did
make some changes to suit the film most
of the characters in the movie either
aren't in the book or have been altered
from the book but the most notable
change to how the story actually feels
is the ending which hyzer are purposely
altered to make more hopeful but despite
these changes neither version of the
story wraps up with an obvious sequel
hook one approach producers could take
is to look at another Malheur Minh novel
black mad wheel for a similar glimpse
into a world where
people's senses start betraying them in
that book a group of musicians is sent
to an African desert to determine the
source of a sound that's wreaking havoc
on the population perhaps this
phenomenon could be tied in with the
monsters from Byrd box which caused
insanity onsite of course there's no
rule saying that there has to be source
material to continue a franchise Game of
Thrones has famously surpassed George RR
Martin's Original Song of Ice and Fire
novels in its final seasons with the
author giving the show's producers
permission to guide the story how they
see fit Netflix could try for a similar
arrangement with malar Minh the point is
they don't need source material to keep
the story spinning especially
considering how much the movie already
deviated from the book
not long after Byrd box was crowned to
success
People magazine asked Suzanne bier if
she'd be interested in directing a
sequel beer was non-committal saying
quote we only just finished it
encouraging fans to thoroughly enjoy the
first movie before clamouring for
another but she was also clearly happy
with the movies reception and that kind
of popular acclaim might be just the
thing to inspire the filmmaker to
explore a second go-around it's easy to
see why a project like Bert box would
attract a talent like beer the
award-winning director has a long resume
of films that focus on families and
times of crisis most notably 2010's
Oscar winning in a better world bird Fox
features plenty of the same themes but
with a sci-fi twist beer also seems to
be interested in exploring themes of
motherhood in late 2018 she signed on to
direct HBO's limited series the undoing
in which big little lies star Nicole
Kidman plays a woman left to rebuild a
life with her young son after a series
of devastating revelations about her
husband with that kind of work under her
belt there's little surprise that beer
would be attracted to telling the story
of Mallory raising the kids she never
wanted it was also the directors first
attempt at a horror film while she has
no sequels in her filmography now a
follow-up to Byrd box could involve a
deeper exploration of the themes the
first movie introduced possibly being
enough to interest beer and her
collaborators in another trip down the
river it was a classic end-of-the-world
love story boy meets girl girl hates boy
before too long
boy and girl end up getting to know one
another on top of a washing machine it
could be the start of something
beautiful but how does it end the last
time we saw Felix and Lucy they were
sneaking into the garage to steal the
recently deceased
Gregg's car and leaving the rest of the
housemates stranded when asked about it
by people susanne bier left the couple's
destination up to the imagination saying
i actually think it's quite exciting
that we don't know exactly where they
went
rosa Salazar who played Lucy in the
movie has her own idea of what happens
next for the duo
she told the Los Angeles Times that she
imagines the pair surviving and
realizing that leaving the house was the
best possible outcome Salazar described
her sequel as a combination of true
romance and Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas with both characters evading death
thanks to their indulging in the
temporary insanity of drugs and alcohol
the idea of the two young lovers
speeding down the highway like a
psychedelic Bonnie and Clyde has some
appeal to it yet it begs the question of
what happens when they run out of gas or
worse yet out of drugs if the filmmakers
decide to take the franchise in an NGO
direction they might want to give
Salazar a call Byrd box has drawn
comparisons to a quiet place with both
movies being thrillers about families
trying to evade monsters that kill by
taking advantage of one of the senses
unlike a quiet place bird box never
shows the creatures but that wasn't
necessarily by design Sandra Bullock
admitted that she filmed a scene with
one of the creatures but it was
eventually scrapped probably for the
best since the original design for the
monsters mostly made her laugh
that didn't stop fans from wondering
what the monsters looked like in place
of actually seeing a visualization of
the monster the final version of the
movie has a scene in which the monster
allied Gary sketches a series of
disturbing images supposedly based on
what the monsters looked like to him it
was good enough for one movie but
there's really only so long that you can
leave the bad guys off screen while
maintaining suspense any sequel would
have to give audiences at least a
glimpse of what's causing all the horror
if the filmmakers decide to stick with
the current look they'll have to figure
out a way to make the creatures a lot
less laughable making the end of the
world great we know what the bird box
monsters do to people but we don't know
much beyond that in the movie lil rel
Howery scare achter Charlie has his own
theory on what the monsters are likening
them to the demons that live in the
mythology of every civilization
spiritual traditions all different names
but the same thing no what's that the
end of us in real life is a credit for
that goes to hi sir who came up with the
idea on his own in malar mans original
book the author never gave his bad guys
a back story instead the screenwriter
dug into various legends and folklore to
create a plausible origin for the
monsters it's another way in which bird
box differs from a quiet place John
Krasinski says he created an entire
history for his monsters in order to
better understand them bird box on the
other hand isn't really concerned with
the nature of the hostile invaders
though Heisler has admitted that he drew
some inspiration from the mysterious
aliens in his 2016 movie arrival that
still doesn't fully answer the question
of whether bird boxes monsters are
aliens spirits or something even
stranger did these creatures arrived on
earth from somewhere else or have they
always been here if so what woke them up
the characters speculate that before you
go crazy and commit suicide you see
images of something from your past
that's believed to involve a deep sense
of loss or intense sadness lydia wonders
if she sees her dead parents just
moments before taking a seat behind the
steering wheel of a burning car
mallory was unsuccessfully tempted by
tom's disembodied voice to take off her
blindfold and were still wondering what
made the track suit wearing woman in the
hospital want to start smashing her head
into a glass window we may never find
out what the brain-scrambling final
images really are because very few
people are left alive to talk about it
the ones that do live through their
encounters with the monsters don't seem
all that reliable turning into homicidal
maniacs wanting to share their ideas of
something beautiful
considering the varied responses it's
hard to imagine that everyone's saying
the same thing one person's beauty could
be another person's nightmare we're
still trying to figure out what could be
so beautiful as to inspire a new mother
to take a running header out of a
second-floor window Americans like to
think of themselves as a can-do bunch
which could explain how a plucky bunch
from Northern California figured out how
to evade certain death from an unseen
Minnis but the movie establishes that
the arrival of the monsters is a
spreading global phenomenon suggesting
that there may be many other groups
around the world to have figured out
some way to stay alive in the face of a
mass
Calamity when the movie opens we learned
that the panic has hit Europe and is
spreading quickly but we also never see
the solutions other people around the
world come up with since the film has
already taken liberties with the source
material it wouldn't be a stretch for
the filmmakers to examine the panic from
another part of the world to see how
diverse groups of people are coping if a
sequel wanted to stay a little closer to
home a potential storyline could follow
the residents of the Janet Tucker School
for the Blind while the students weren't
in any danger of being driven to suicide
they almost certainly came into contact
with people who are afflicted how long
did it take them to understand what was
happening and why they weren't stricken
with madness it would also be
interesting to discover how the school
became a haven for refugees seeking
shelter now that Mallory and the kids
have made it to the safety of the
compound they're all ready to start new
lives yet we have no clue what those
lives will be like from all appearances
the people sheltered inside the school
for the blind are leading happy
productive lives but it's hard to
believe that it will be peace and
harmony forever more people are likely
to come looking for help there's also
the chance that the deranged will come
looking to create chaos and there are
still unseen Horrors looking to do
damage outside the walls a potential
sequel could see Tom and Olympia
becoming acclimated to their new society
and also show the school training its
residents to survive in the outside
world if the people inside gain enough
knowledge of what the creatures actually
are they could come up with a plan to
eventually defeat them or the kids could
simply choose to live out their days and
tranquility building relationships with
the people they meet in their new living
situation it'd be a happy ending even if
it might not be the most exciting sequel
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]